eine stadt wird zur großstadt wenn die
einwohnerzahl die grenze von 100.000
überschreitet so viel wie deutschland
bisher an corona toten zu beklagen hat
das ist die schreckliche dimension der
pandemie und besserung ist nicht in
sicht im gegenteil jetzt also die ganz
starke dosis
deutschland in der vierten welle helfen
nur impfpflicht und lockdown heute in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist durch
neubauer sie sind parteiloser
bürgermeister der stadt augustusburg in
sachsen rund 5000 einwohner liegt im
landkreis mittelsachsen und da gibt es
eine 7 tage insolvenz von 1011 mit
aktuellen stephan andreas casdorff ist
bei uns herausgeber des berliner
tagesspiegels
und zugeschaltet sind die
wissenschaftsjournalisten christina
berndt von der süddeutschen zeitung
und der allgemeinmediziner wolfgang
kaiser
vorsitzender des hausärzteverbandes
berlin-brandenburg neubauer geben sie
uns doch mal eine aktuelle stimmungslage
aus augustusburg ich habe schon gesagt
so eine sogenannte korona hotspot im
moment wieder aus natürlich kommen die
stadt liegt noch etwas unter der
insolvenz des landkreises sondern ich
ganz zustimmen gleich ist mittlerweile
bei dem vierfachen dessen liegt was wir
vorher als höchststände hatten ja die
stimmung ist
schwankt zwischen verängstigt und und
trotzig das sind so glaube ich die
beiden gruppen wir sind haben es gerade
25 tage organisiert und der stadt für 29
30 11
die kolleginnen die die hotline gemacht
hat muss ich jetzt erst mal urlaub
schicken also es war ein unfassbar an
tragen die leute sind dann auch sehr
aufgebracht wird das nicht klappt manche
decken sich mit mehreren terminen ist
gerade ganz eingeladen wo sie zeichnen
den weil gerade ja in der gegend auch
die impfquote nicht so hoch ist herr
kaiser auch an die frage wie sieht es
denn aus in den hausarztpraxen nach der
booster kampagne nach g2 nach g2 plus
und jetzt auch noch nach der impfstoff
rationierung also betreffend den
impfstoff biontech
naja die sachen kennen wir ja schon wir
haben ja im sommer auch noch mal eine
rationierung und stadt dass herr sparen
von fehlern gelernt hat hat er das
wieder gemacht wir hatten andere
rationierung das biotec impfstoffes aber
wir hatten schon termine vergeben was
das in der praxis bedeutet kann sich
niemand vorstellen dass patienten die
jetzt schon einen termin haben müssen
angerufen werden um zu bekommen spätere
termine das schafft viel um das personal
ist am limit
verwehren neben der fürther corona welle
rollt jetzt noch eine andere welle auf
uns zu nämlich die anschwellende
diskussion über die impfpflicht
inzwischen ist eine mehrheit laut
umfragen dafür auch der widerstand in
der politik gegen eine impfpflicht der
brücke ja zusehens
kommt sie denn eigentlich diese
impfpflicht wenn die pandemie gar nicht
mehr anders in den griff zu kriegen ist
daran kann man im moment fast ausgehen
also die stimmen die man so hört die
sind eben alle inzwischen doch sehr sehr
deutlich pro impfpflicht selbst aus der
fdp kommen ja zum teil solche signale
und von daher kann es gut sein dass die
politik hier ihr versprechen bricht was
sie ja eigentlich seit beginn der
pandemie immer mehr immer wiederholt hat
dass es keine solche impfpflicht für
alle geben werde da kannst du eine
impfpflicht wenn sie denn käme würde ja
wenn überhaupt nur mittelfristig helfen
da ein lock down ist da viel wirksamer
also weihnachten im hausarrest
ja ich glaube schon also wir wollen
diese welle brechen und mindestens
kontakt fischer fw nennen dass er jetzt
nicht mehr locker weil ja die politik
versprochen hat es werde keinen doktor
umgeben um die menschen wie wir das aber
die empörung den trotz nicht zu groß
werden zu lassen muss man das schon
anders nennen das übel sondern
herausforderungen die kommunikation es
wird strenge kontakt beschränkungen
geben müssen so nennen wir das jetzt mal
anders wird es gar nicht mehr gehen was
mich allerdings wundert dass wir soweit
es haben kommen lassen also man konnte
es kommen sehen und wir haben es also
nicht wie aber die politik hat es so
weit kommen dass manchmal erinnert mich
das ich glaube es war karl kraus an den
satz politik ist genauso wie sich klein
fritzchen politik vorstellt wenn wahr
ist was ich ja zu staunen zur kenntnis
genommen aber das ist gar kein
krisenstab im kanzleramt gegeben hat den
jetzt olaf scholz neue präventive
bundeskanzler heinrich kabinett soll es
gegeben kroner kabinett aber einen
krisenstab unter fachleuten also
virologen und das ist ein unterschied zu
epidemiologen aber virologen apple die
meldung soziologen
psychologen all das in einem krisenstab
hat es gibt schon längst ich bin da
offen sich idealistisch oder naiv
gewesen das wäre ja grotesk wenn es das
so nicht gegeben hätte ja es hat die mpk
gegeben also die
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz im verein
mit angela merkel aber ich glaube dass
das eine sehr gute einrichtung ist und
ich glaube dass die auch sachgerecht
urteil mit außerdem werden mal andere zu
wort kommen andere biologen
epidemiologen psychologen als wir sie
bis jetzt gehört die werden jetzt aber
dem virus erst mal nicht das was man
nicht abrücken können das wird noch eine
zeit lang dauern
kreischer wie sie denn eigentlich das
szenario jetzt für den winter aus ihrer
sicht wie sich das jetzt
weiterentwickelt die inzidenz ziehen die
hospitalisierung rate also die
einlieferung quote in krankenhäuser die
steigt unaufhörlich die zahl der
neuinfektionen die zahl der korona
verstorbenen steigt unaufhörlich und wie
man das so plötzlich immer sagt die
intensivstation laufen voll welches
szenario erwarten sieben winter
ja zunächst mal aus unserer sicht als
hausarzt hier einen unglaublichen
ansturm von patienten im moment man muss
dazu sagen wir haben ja natürlich die
regelversorgung aufrecht zu erhalten das
darf man nicht vergessen daneben müssen
wir jetzt gegen korona und wir müssen
auch gegen dritten gegen die entzündung
das stellt uns vor große herausforderung
insgesamt muss man natürlich sagen das
ist ja nur eine maßnahme gegen die
pandemie abstandsregeln das wurde eben
schon gesagt müssen weiter eingehalten
werden und es ist auch klar jeder
geimpfte kann ja trotzdem das virus
weiter tragen dass punkt kann auch
krankheits durchbrüche geben also impft
durchbrüche so dass geimpfte auch krank
werden das gibt zwar leichtere verläufe
aber nach und nach wird es eine
durchsuchung in der gewinnung geben ich
denke da kommen wir nicht drum um robert
liegt auch das problem vielleicht darin
dass zwar die ungeimpften jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit angegangen und attackiert
werden aber das vielleicht viele
geimpfte auch viel zu sorglos sind so
nach dem motto ich bin ja geimpft also
eigentlich kann ich ja was
abstandsregeln masken pflicht alles das
was
ja auch das virus eindämmt brauche ich
gar nicht mehr machen weil ich bin ja
geimpft und zweifachen geben und
vielleicht auch noch gepustet
die kommunikation hat sicher zu spät
begonnen in diese richtung auch den
geimpften deutlich zu machen ihr seid
auch noch teil des geschehens nicht man
hat immer von einer pandemie der
ungeimpften gesprochen und das ist
natürlich auch zu einem großen teil war
die inzidenz 'nen unter den ungeimpften
sind ja um ein vielfaches höher um den
faktor 20 mancher orts als die decke
impfen also insofern schon die geimpften
spielen im moment die größere rolle als
die ungeimpften sagte ich das spielen im
moment die größere rolle aber klar die
geimpften können sich auch anstecken
können das virus weiter verbreiten
insofern muss man das den menschen auch
sagen und es ist sehr wichtig dass wir
jetzt immer mehr dahin kommen dass sich
bitte auch geimpfte weiter testen lassen
und dass alle menschen in diesem land
ihre kontakte runter fahren denn so wie
es jetzt läuft laufen wir tatsächlich
auf eine katastrophe zu wir haben jetzt
ja die täglich 50 60.000 neuinfektionen
und diese menschen die sich da jetzt
anstecken von denen wird ein großer ein
erklecklicher anteil schwer krank werden
und im krankenhaus behandelt werden
müssen auf intensivstationen behandelt
werden müssen wo wir jetzt schon zum
teil keine betten mehr haben das was sie
jetzt beklagen karlsdorf das ist ja
eigentlich seit langem bekannt es wurde
immer wieder gewarnt von medizinern von
biologen virologen was jetzt kommt das
ist keine überraschung es ähnelt ja auch
den vorgängen im letzten jahr das man so
ich meine jetzt die politik so sehenden
auges in die vierte welle rauscht und
sich selbst unsere nachbarn oder weit
entfernte länder länder wie brasilien
die neulich noch ganz schlecht hatten
sich verwundert die augen reiben was ist
da eigentlich in deutschland los ist
dass politiker sagen ist das zu wenig
kommunikation im öffentlichen raum
zwischen bürgerinnen und bürgern und
politik was wie gesagt war ja mit ansage
und zwar über wochen wahrscheinlich so
eine melange also es kann nicht sein was
nicht sein darf der mensch macht sich
auch seine welt so wie sie ihm gefällt
dass man hat gehofft dass das jetzt im
griff sei aber man hätte wissen können
dass frühling und sommer helfen gegen
kroner und dann wird es wieder eng und
das wusste man ja schon vorher wir sind
in so eine welle reingelaufen und dann
auch so behauptung naja aber so
behauptungen wie wenn du geimpft bist
kriegst du deine freiheit wieder es
wurde eine frist wurde eine fatale eine
gewisse sorglosigkeit ja auch provoziert
die leute haben wirklich geglaubt die
menschen haben geglaubt zu einer großen
anteil ich bin geimpft alles wird gut
das wird auch den trotz das wird die
empörung hervor ich habe doch alles
gemalt wie kann das eigentlich sein also
ich glaube dass wir hier eine pokales
kollektiv vorsagen sehen also sowohl von
der bevölkerung ansicht 3 macht man sich
wohl jeder der halbwegs
die ersten wellen verarbeitet hat wusste
was kommen wird und also von der politik
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ist dass das
der schlimmste anzunehmende unfall den
der jetzt passiert gerade wir haben ja
wirklich zu jedem zeitpunkt alles falsch
gemacht wir haben die impfzentren
geschlossen als es als es hätte heißen
müssen wir müssen impfen wir haben die
kostenpflicht zu tests eingeführt in der
illusion dass eigentlich man würde den
widerstand brechen und die leute würden
scharenweise die nicht mehr vorhandenen
impfzentren stürmen
wo jeder auf der auf kommunaler ebene
ist wusste dass das nur noch mehr den
widerstand bevölkerung ist etwas
leichter und und damit haben wir gerade
im ländlichen raum ist es verheerend und
dass das feld des ktm auf die füße
stellt alle haben durch die
kostenpflicht die vorhandene test
infrastruktur eingelegt und zwar über
nacht im ritz brauchen wir sie wieder es
war ein akzeptiertes system die leute
sind testen gegangen und so lange
wussten wir halbwegs was los ist wenn
ich mir jetzt die zahlen hoch
erzgebirgskreis steuert auf eine
insolvenz von 2.400 zu wenn die zahlen
so weitergehen wenn wir das
herunterrechnen sind wir bei der insel
denn 20 gipfel von über 10.000 da werden
wissen wir jetzt schon dass das hunderte
sterben werden das ist unfassbar und wir
müssen doch irgendwann mal sagen leute
was haben wir den letzten sommer gemacht
wie ihr bürgermeisteramt von april an
weiß ich ich hatte im april im ersten
brief an unsere starts kristall
geschrieben habe sagt wir hatten unser
öffnungs projekt in augustusburg für
wissen wie tests funktionieren lasst uns
weiter testen lasst uns das strategie
vor dem herbst finden ich bin ausgelacht
worden und jetzt das ende vom lied ist
das jetzt und das kann man auch nicht
nicht nicht dem bürger alleine zu weisen
hier ist auch wirklich politik immer vor
allem das wort land politik außen
sondern wenn nicht sogar besser doch
tatsache ist aber einen punkt der mich
nämlich besonders ärgert ist die zahl
der intensivbetten das immer weiter
gesunken immer weiter gesunken wir haben
keine pflegekräfte jede fünfte pflege
sehe ich kann nicht mehr ich will nicht
mehr wir haben keine im ausland
angeworben wir haben keine prämien
ausgelobt wir haben keine menschen
befähigt er tüchtig das zu übernehmen
wir haben nicht wir haben nicht genug
wir haben nicht genug intensivbetten das
sind 22.000 sinken wir wollten mal
40.000 haben so und von diesen sind
natürlich jetzt haben wir 17 18 prozent
belegt mit corona patienten das wird
steigen aber der rest muss ja auch
irgendwie bedient werden also das ist
auch so ein versagen das kann ich
überhaupt nicht verstehen wie das
geschehen konnte und auch jetzt gott sei
dank hat die neue bundesregierung mal
positiv nicht wahr die hat reagiert und
gesagt es muss ein bonus geben wir
müssen menschen anreizen das zu tun was
wir dringend brauchen als gesetzlicher
keine virologen ich habe frau berndt es
ist ja die delta variante die so
verheerend wirkt das wissen
wissenschaftler und die leute vom fach
schon seit längerem offensichtlich die
politik auch aber sie hat es nicht
richtig kommuniziert ist das unter
anderem auch ein kommunikationsdesaster
den leuten auch klar zu machen was da
eigentlich gerade passiert mit mit dem
corona virus und dass wir da immer
hinter den entwicklungen hinter dem
eigentlich notwendigen informationsstand
hinterherhecheln
ich sehe es eigentlich so dass die
politiker selber nicht begriffen hat
also die daten lagen ja auf dem tisch
wissenschaftler innen haben ganz
deutlich gewarnt wenn wir so eine
impfquote wie wir sie jetzt haben nicht
überschreiten dann wird das nicht
reichen und dann werden wir zahlen haben
wie wir sie noch nie gesehen haben und
das hat die politik ja bis vor ein paar
wochen nicht verstanden als man eben nur
dann die nationale notlage abzuschaffen
als man von freedom day schwadronierte
das ist erst wirklich mit den steigenden
inzidenz wieder in die köpfe hinein wir
kommen zu den intensivbetten würde ich
gerne noch sagen ja auch das ist
natürlich ein versagen dass man nicht
schon längst den pflegekräften ja auch
andere anreize geboten hat aber
eigentlich müssten wir ja verhindern
dass menschen überhaupt so krank werden
dass sie diese intensivbetten wegen
mobil 19 brauchen und da sehe ich das
ursprüngliche versagen dass wir eben es
nicht geschafft haben die instanzen im
zaum zu halten das jahr mit dem kopf
geschüttelt jetzt
ja das hat jetzt keinen sinn sich an
einzelnen sachen hoch zuzüglich nur das
letzte beispiel mit den intensivbetten
auch eine verdopplung der intensivbetten
bringt nichts wir haben das personal
nicht personal wälder ausgerufen
die helferinnen sind am limit jetzt hat
sich das erste mal herr sparen für einem
seiner fehler entschuldigt er hat ja
fast nur fehler gemacht aus meiner sicht
nicht weil ihr habt nicht mit uns
gesprochen das ist das hauptproblem der
viel gelegenheit wieder dazu nicht mehr
haben jetzt noch etwa 14 tage im amt
nachts kurz weil wir reden immer von den
pflegerinnen und pflegern in den in den
krankenhäusern aus intensivstationen
auch von denen in den altenheimen aber
sie haben es ja gerade geschildert auch
die hausarztpraxen werden ja regelrecht
überrannt physisch oder telefonisch was
bedeutet das eigentlich für die
mitarbeiter in den arztpraxen für die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter das
sind ja nicht nur ärzte dort unterwegs
sondern auch viele die eine arztpraxis
am laufen halten
naja dann muss die pflegekräfte um die
mfs in einem atemzug nennen weil dort
als im krankenhaus passiert das passiert
auch in den praxen der beruf wird
unattraktiv wir schieben einem berg von
überstunden vor uns her und wir wissen
nicht wie wir dieses personal bezahlen
sollen auch da ist die allem in die
alimentierung für die impfung für das
impfen zu schlecht gewesen also alles
was gemacht wurde wurde
fehlerbehaftet gemacht wurde falsch
gemacht also rein statistisch ist es so
dass man mehr fehler gemacht hat alles
richtig mache ich mal um rückblickend
muss ich sagen dass bei der ganzen kann
denn die bekämpfung die politik eher
geschadet als genutzt das ist meine
harte behandlung sprechen jetzt nur über
corona und die fanden wir sprechen nicht
über andere sachen wie geht afghanistan
und kabinen dass man kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen was für viele entscheidungen
dieses land trifft und insofern wir
haben einen appell an die neue regierung
einfach mal mit den beteiligten mit uns
ärztinnen und ärzten und der front zu
sprechen sich zu entscheiden aber ist
dass sich inzwischen in bremen muss
vertreter der ärzte und ärztinnen auch
nicht gerade
beigetragen haben zu einer besseren
bewältigung dieser pandemie wenn ich da
an herrn gassen denke als den obersten
kassenwarts vertreter der immer wieder
darüber fabuliert hat dass man jetzt
aber da keine maßnahmen mehr braucht und
die lage gar nicht so schlimm sei also
da wäre es schön wenn ärzte und
ärztinnen da auch demnächst für bessere
vertreter sorgen würden aber ist es
nicht ist es nicht inzwischen
tatsächlich eher so ein symbol dafür
dass in diesem land generell irgendwas
nicht richtig funktioniert also ich bin
ich will jetzt nicht die hoffnung
bemühen an eine neue bundesregierung
dass sie sollen ihre chance bekommen die
die erwartungshaltung ist gebremst aber
trotzdem muss man ja sagen wir haben ja
generell offensichtlichen problemen und
ordnet immer wieder richtige
entscheidungen dem votum der umfragen
unter und der tagesaktuellen
großwetterlage unter also ich teile die
meinung nicht dass politik nicht hätte
wissen können was da passiert ich glaube
tatsächlich und so weit würde ich ihr
auch gegen japan versucht eine
bundestagswahl zu retten und hat das
wirklich alles den wind geschlagen mit
mit freedom day und diesem ganzen unsinn
erzählt worden ist jeder
kommunalvertreter der der das gehört hat
er wusste was was vor ort los das hat
nun kopf frisch ist also was macht ihr
da es gibt keine kommunikation mehr
bottom up es geht nur noch von oben nach
unten das wird irgendwie irgendwas
beschlossenen durchdekliniert und ich
finde das muss aufhören dieses land ist
viel zu komplex diese ist die
problemlagen sind viel zu komplex das
geht so nicht mehr wir werden künftig
wirklich mehr miteinander aushandeln
müssen und noch ein letzter satz was mir
wirklich auf dem herz nicht weil das
auch hier das zentrale problem ist
politik hat nicht die kraft klartext zu
sprechen man hätte ganz klar sagen
müssen wenn das so nicht funktioniert
dann wird es eine impfpflicht geben aber
diese kraft hat man immer politik
offensichtlich dass die probleme noch
felix und moderiert die so oft mit den
konjunktiv benutzen musste selbst wenn
es um politische taktiererei in einem
wahlkampf jahr geht das ist ja nichts
überraschendes aber dass gerade die
impfkampagne nicht so verfangen hat wie
wir uns das oder wie man tatsächlich
eigentlich jetzt wünscht woran lag das
denn eigentlich denn gegen simpson war
ja von pfund kroner leuten abgesehen hat
mich niemand
die frage habe ich also erst das ebenso
aufgaben habe ich auch eben darüber
nachgedacht aber ich muss gleich darauf
zurückkommen also ich glaube dass
politik und dann komme ich auf die
impfkampagne dass politik schon auf die
ausstellen auftrag hat das wissen über
parlamente abgewickelt zu werden es gibt
eine volksvertretung und die
volksvertreter sind aufgerufen sich
damit zu befassen die können das auch
sehr schnell das geht auch bis hin zum
bundesrat sehr schnell ich finde es sehr
gut dass diese koalition etwas achtet
was für unsere für das konstitutiv was
das konstitutives element unserer
demokratie ist also das ist zurück
bringt in die parlamente die sehr
schnell reagieren können ich finde auch
dass die maßnahmen die der gemachtem
hospitalisierung rate diesen drei zahlen
369 das ist alles zu kommunizieren ja
das problem ist kommunikation ist nicht
nur einfach gesabbel kommt vom
lateinischen kommunika heißt im
weitesten sinne gemeinsam schaffen was
sie hätten schaffen müssen es eine
gemeinsamkeit gefühl und zu sagen was
man auch wir müssen das gemeinsam
angehen und zwar die parlamente werden
sachgerecht entscheiden wir wissen alles
wir suchen uns in sachverstand und wir
werden nicht in minister
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen die
somit der kanzlerin gar nicht gegeben
hat top down entscheiden sondern wir
werden uns die leute holen mit dem reden
was ist eine sachgerechte politische
lösung und bei der im körper an habe ich
mich immer gefragt warum gibt es
eigentlich nicht wie in anderen ländern
eine belohnung wenn du dich impfen lässt
in drei gottes namen was wäre in diesem
staat was wäre uns verloren gegangen
weil wir gesagt werden dafür gibt's geld
oder dafür gibt es irgendwas ich glaube
das ist tatsächlich für manche ein
anreiz gewesen wäre wir hätten viel mehr
machen oder versuchen müssen trial and
error ich sage nicht dass in wien israel
gehen kann weil die israelis ganz andere
datensätze über die menschen haben die
da leben ja viele waren beim militär und
du weißt wie du sie erreicht und wo du
sie erreicht aber dass es andere sehr
viel einfacher schaffen als wir und
jetzt frage ich mich es in anderen
ländern noch zu geht wo die instanzen
noch höher sind als bei uns wir liegen
in europa nach den letzten charge ich
gesehen habe noch nicht mal unter den
top 20 was die instanzen angehen um
gottes willen das ist ja ein
gesamteuropäischer sagte noch eine
nachfrage dazu was jetzt gerade gesagt
haben sie haben ja dass das grundrecht
des grundrechts aspekt da mit einbezogen
zu sagen das muss wieder die
entscheidung muss wieder zurück in die
parlamente verlagert werden das ist ja
ein wichtiges thema auch gewesen und
diese
biologische verlangte beteiligung aller
tragweite wieder abzuschaffen am ende
ist er dabei herausgekommen dass diese
dass eine grundrechts frage contra der
pandemie bekämpfung war das heißt es
wurde sozusagen als alternative entweder
wollt ihr eure grundrechte zurück oder
wir bekämpfen effektiv die pandemie so
ist es ja in der öffentlichkeit
diskutiert worden war das so klug oder
ist die richtige analyse nein ich glaube
nicht außerdem ist es werden überall
grundrechte eingeschränkt und wenn da
muss das parlament eben schnell
beteiligt werden ob das jetzt über die
mpk und die kanzlerin ob das das
richtige war das ist jetzt auch
verschüttete milch wir müssen jetzt weit
nach vorne denken und das muss jetzt
schneller gehen und ich muss noch mal
sagen die maßnahmen die sachgerecht
beschlossen worden sind mit einem
krisenstab im kanzleramt ich meine die
werden sehr viel schneller reagieren
können als wir denken und dann gehen sie
ins parlament tragen und wir tun immer
so als ob die abgeordnete darum sie
essen und nicht wissen was sie tun ein
die werden sofort zusammen gerufen das
ist von der untersten ebene bis zur
obersten sehr schnell als mir ein
bisschen mehr vertrauen in unsere
volksvertreter hätte ja auch schon gerne
ich glaube dass wir sehr viel
sachgerechter jetzt vorankommen und die
verschärfung die verband der sich
wünschen auch erneut die wird sie
ergeben es ist ja nicht so als ob das
nicht gesehen würde es ist aber ein
neuer blick nötig und nicht immer nur
die werden schon entscheiden die werden
das schon richtig machen nein
offensichtlich ja nicht offensichtlich
war so ist so getrimmt verbrennt wollte
da glaube ich dazu doch was sagen diese
gibt es dennoch verschärfungen ohne
impfpflicht und lock down oder haben wir
eigentlich nur noch die wahl nicht
zwischen den beiden sondern die beiden
dann tatsächlich jetzt auch anzugehen
es gibt natürlich noch steigerungen von
verschärfungen in manchen bundesländern
gibt es die ja auch schon wir haben ja
zum teil schon ausgangssperren
gesungen also schließzeiten nach hinten
hinein wir haben zum teil der zweig plus
regeln jetzt auch also dass da gibt es
ja schon inzwischen regionale
unterschiede und möglichkeiten dinge zu
verstehen und noch ich wollte gern noch
was zu dieser impfquote sagen weshalb
man das so unterschätzt hat und
vielleicht da auch zu wenig getan hat
ich glaube da muss man einfach sehen das
ist ja immer umfragen gab wie vielen
menschen wollen sich impfen lassen auch
gut gemachte studien gerade von der uni
erfurt die da ja ganz lange schon dran
ist die menschen in diesen dingen
professionell abzufragen und da sah es
am anfang eben so aus als würden sich
sehr viel mehr menschen impfen lassen
und dann begann über den sommer hinweg
eine grandiose desinformationskampagne
eben in sozialen medien wo menschen dann
sich so verunsichern ließen wo ängste
geschürt wurden massiven ausmaßes also
so dass wir dann jetzt plötzlich
erkennen müssen es gibt in diesem land
kaum noch jemanden der noch geimpft
werden will wenn er es noch nicht ist
und das ist natürlich das große dilemma
wo wir versagt haben den menschen
bessere informationen und vertrauen an
die hand zu geben
also erstens mal ist es so dass man
jetzt nicht einen arzt heranziehen kann
und davon das system versagen ableitet
herr gassen ist nicht ein arzt der an
der front arbeitet vergessen ist ein
vertreter einer körperschaft das ist mal
was ganz anderes
ich denke wir sind an der front ihr als
hausärzte um alles das was jetzt an
statistiken mit im verweigerern und
sonstwas ausgearbeitet wird das erlebe
ich jeden tag zwar in kleineren maße
oder die informationen könnten viel
schneller an die politik heran getreten
werden wenn man sagen würde wie ist es
denn bei ihnen heute in der praxis
lassen sich andere impfen oder lassen
sich nicht alle impfen dann haben sie
die informationen direkt und brauchen
nicht erst noch eine uni beauftragen
ohne statistik machen ein halbes jahr
dauert mit der erkenntnis jawoll abends
wird es dunkel und auch jetzt wieder
hell dass dennoch binsenweisheiten
insofern man muss miteinander reden aber
es müssen auch die richtigen akteure
miteinander reden wenn sie den
kammerpräsidenten fragen oder den
ärztepräsident montgomery hat mal gesagt
ganz am anfang man weiß gar nicht ob
meine maske was nützt ja himmel noch mal
ist würde doch sich kein mensch von
einem operateur operieren lassen wer
ohne maske arbeitet insofern solche
sachen dürfen überhaupt nicht an die
öffentlichkeit kommen wenn
verantwortliche menschen so locker
machen klappt sich mal was sagen deshalb
die akteure gehören zusammen an einem
tisch um das sind dann nicht
standesvertreter gehören lassen sondern
das sind dann die hausärzte um die
gehirne der riesenstadt und niemand
anderes
darf ich da noch eine frage
anschliessend ergreift sie haben jetzt
von kampagnen gesprochen dass
informationen dass da dinge an die
öffentlichkeit geraten sind die gleich
hätten hingehört weil sie einfach nur
verwirrung stiften das bezog sich jetzt
oder bezieht sich nicht nur auf die
impfkampagne sondern auch auf die
impfstoff kampagnen ich erinnere mich
dass es eine diskussion gab und eine
richtige kampagne in der öffentlichkeit
aber nicht nur die medien beteiligt das
us-tor senica viel zu wenig wirksam sei
dann blieb dieser stoff in den
kühlschränken liegen jetzt haben wir
noch eine ähnliche situation gehabt dass
offenbar bei entdeckt von den meisten
viel mehr geschätzt wird als moderner
das wurde dann so von manchen
hingestellt zwei moderner der
schmächtige bruder von beyond es sind ja
beides m rna impfstoffe jetzt hat man
große probleme die menschen die sich
jetzt boostern lassen wollen es wollen
er sich auch viele auch wegen g2 und g2
plus erst impfen lassen dass man ihn
jetzt nicht versorgen kann mit biontech
dass es zu wenig bionic und viel zu viel
moderner gibt die man da nicht mehr
impfen kann die können übrigens aus
vertragsrechtlichen gründen auch nicht
exportiert werden in entwicklungsländer
was ist bei dieser impfstoff kampagne
eigentlich schiefgelaufen was muss man
das verstehen was da passiert ist wer
anders wirtschaftliche interessen oder
wollte man da jeden tag eine andere sau
durchs dorf jagen
was behindert und ist weiß ich nicht ich
weiß nicht wer von welcher firma aktien
hat ob der wirtschaftliche interessen
dahinter stehen oder nicht das kann ich
nicht beurteilen
ich kann nur feststellen
man durch solche aktionen dass man
beispielsweise den achsen einfach die
impfdosen reduziert habe ärzte
verschreckt hat ich habe jetzt nicht die
zahlen bundesweit ich kann so für berlin
sagen es hatten im sommer 3000 baxley
geimpft und jetzt winken weniger als
2000 wachsen das hat mehrere gründe aber
ein grund ist zum beispiel auch diese
desinformation diese rationierung
natürlich auch das finanzielle und der
frust der helferinnen die werden gar
nicht anerkannt es heißt in der
öffentlichkeit in der pflege
personalintensiv pflegerinnen und
pfleger aber die mfa stehende aus und
ganz vorne und deshalb sind diese
multiplikatoren die hausarztpraxen und
auch die facharztpraxen aus dem jüngst
geschehen
raus teilweise und das ist ein großer
fehler das hätte nicht passieren dürfen
und das wäre auch nicht passiert ich bin
leider beim konjunktiv wieder wenn dann
miteinander geredet hätte im fleisch
können da das in zukunft an besser
machen das ist kein konjunktiv das ist
würde ich glaube tatsächlich dass du ja
dass das der schlüssel ist und ein ganz
wichtiges schlüsselwort ist vertrauen
wenn sie die qualität nicht vertrauen
vertrauen sowie die ziemlich einfach ist
das also das ist tatsächlich das was da
im osten jetzt hauptsächlich sich
niederschlägt und vornehmlich in sachsen
aber auch in thüringen und auch in
teilen von bayern in diesem
konservativen gegenden wo das ohnehin
traditionell anders läuft diese diese
welle die danieder bricht über über
ungeimpfte ich werbe auch fürs impfen
aber im trotzdem können wir nicht können
wir nicht ungeimpfte sozusagen
gleichsetzen mit mit allen negativen was
wir sonst um politische spektrum
bereithalten so zu sagen wir müssen sie
zurückgewinnen das ist eine
vertrauensfrage die leute sind die leute
haben speziell im osten das vertrauen in
die politik verloren so und demzufolge
waren alle schritte die auf zwang hin
liefen die also quasi dann auch erkannt
wurden als das was es war nämlich quasi
eine impfpflicht durch die hintertür
wenn man die barrieren sonst hochzieht
und sagt es gibt noch zwei g2 g plus was
ist es denn dann am ende und das haben
die leute erkannt und das hat sich
absolut ins kieler nachfragen historiker
der sich mit impfen beschäftigt hat
geschichte historisch hat gesagt
wenn man sich die ins geschichte ansieht
die er schon jahrhunderte andauert
überzeugungsarbeit lohnt sich auf dauer
würden sie das würden sie denen sie
haben viel kontakt mit den bürgerinnen
und alle sind also ich gehe wirklich
ganz fest aber ich merke dass da schon
im kleinen das hat jetzt nichts mit mir
als person zu tun aber man kann überall
dort wo es vertrauen noch gibt in die
kommunalpolitik gibt es in vielen
städten ja noch wenn sich dort jemand
von hinstellt und sagt leute macht das
dann sind die impfquoten anders die
leute richten sich an so was auf sie
sind extrem verunsichert
das muss man einfach zu erkennen sind
ich merke ich spüre dass wirklich in den
gesprächen sind extrem verunsichert und
jetzt und das haben wir gemacht ich
meine mit diesem vor zurück zur seite
ran wir alle wie wir sitzen
beschäftigungs beruflich damit aber der
blogger der hat irgendwie auch noch was
anderes zu tun und das was da in den
überschriften vermittelt bekommen hat in
den letzten monaten waren absolutes
verwirrspiel so und da müssen wir noch
nicht wundern dass die leute sagen hallo
jochen im internet kind eben da hat
gesagt dass das alles mist dass das dann
auf derselben dass das dieselbe
wertigkeit hat die wiener wie eine
offizielle quelle also wir haben hier in
grandiosen vertrauensverlust und
werteverfall und und dass das ist jetzt
eigentlich die aufgabe der politik ist
vertrauen wiederherzustellen und das wir
jetzt versuchen die leute glaube ich mit
akzeptierten maßnahmen wieder auf unsere
seite zu ziehen auf die seite zu sagen
wir müssen das jetzt gemeinsam auch mit
akzeptieren worden tests die wahren
akzeptiert das war mittlerweile wieder
machen das ist ja nicht falsch aber
jetzt sehr viel und das muss man am
anderen ende auch wieder belohnt weil
das was wir jetzt wieder machen wenn
sachsen sachsen redet jetzt wieder vom
lock down wir treiben die leute damit
wieder ins dunkel feld was dann passiert
ist genau das gegenteil wird wir treiben
die ex die die instanzen weil die
menschen dann nicht mehr in die
kontrollierten räume gehen sondern sie
gehen sie treffen sich nur technologisch
die treffen sich dann der garage und um
ihren bier passen und das ist doch das
ist kontraproduktiv dann müssten wir
jetzt einen schritt zurückgehen oder
sage okay vertrauen gegen vertrauen ihr
habt auch eine eigenverantwortung wir
testen jetzt alle und gucken was wir
unter der maßgabe alle werden getestet
möglich machen können und was eben nicht
wir sagen was ist aus meiner sicht als
einzige ausländerin ja jetzt auch leider
zum großen teil geschlossen und bitten
er das ist ja praktikabel also wir reden
über zwei dinge einmal ist so das
vertrauen in die politik ist erodiert ja
aber politik ist ja doch immer noch so
man denkt ist eine art bestenauslese die
wissen bescheid wie es geht am ende
hofft man doch die beschäftigen sich
damit die wissen bescheid nein das ist
das problem stellen fest dass wir
genauso wenig wissen wie wir das ist
kein guter kein gutes gefühl jetzt
allerdings muss man sagen hat ich würde
sagen ich zum apologeten dieser
bundesregierung werden aber das
sachgerechte daran ist in aller ruhe
wieder den alarmismus anti alarmistisch
gewissermaßen zu sagen das ist das was
wir jetzt tun und wir werden das alles
nachvollziehbar und transparent machen
und wenn es nicht reicht dann werden wir
werden wir es nach schärfen wie das so
schön heißt aber richtig ist man könnte
jetzt schon hingehen und sagen was man
auf diese geschichte mit dem test war
ein großer fehler das werden wir
abstellen das wird jetzt wieder
kostenlose tests geben jeder deutsche
kann sich testen und ist zweimal eine
woche bist du dann positiv musst du
sieben tage ist ganz klare regeln
einrichten musste sieben tagen garantien
und kannst dich vorher nicht frei testen
danach gibt es entweder an die gehen
oder pcr wie auch immer das kann man
alles bestimmen das müssen dann die
ärzte wissen und dann ist die sache klar
also bist du positiv gewesen dann gehst
du in garantieren die sieben tage nicht
fünf nicht sieben nicht zählen das geht
ja alles durcheinander von landkreis
mensch von landkreis zu landkreis
manchmal innerhalb einer stadt bei
schulen unterschiedlicher art hast du
unterschiedliche regeln da verstecken er
was du machen das natürlich einen lock
down verhindert frau berndt
die jetzige neue regierung auf die sich
jetzt auch stephan andreas casdorff da
gerade bezogen hat die villa oder
beziehungsweise mit dem heutigen tag ist
diese ausgelaufen die epidemiologische
notlage nationaler tragweite war das ein
sündenfall das auslaufen zu lassen
naja ich verstehe schon bisher casdorff
auch eben gesagt hat nicht dass man die
macht zurück ins parlament geben will
und nicht mehr weiter solche
notstandsgesetze haben will aber
gleichzeitig brauchen wir einfach ein
wirksames instrumentarium es ist
wirklich fünf nach zwölf das wurde ja
nun schon oft genug auch gesagt und ich
bin mir nicht so sicher dass so eine
test strategie alleine jetzt noch helfen
kann wir müssen ja auch bedenken dass
sehr viele menschen die jetzt zu denen
gehören die sich noch nicht haben impfen
lassen ja auch insgesamt eine große
skepsis überhaupt dem konzept corona
virus entgegenbringen und von daher auch
gar nicht bereit sind wirklich da auf
sich zu achten und ansteckungen zu
verhindern ein teil sicher schon ein
teil hat einfach nur angst vor der
impfung möchte diesen impfstoff nicht
haben er kennt ansonsten an das gebiet
eine schwerwiegende krankheit ist die
man möglichst verhindern sollte aber ein
teil eben auch nicht und von daher
fürchte ich dass wir an dem punkt an dem
wir jetzt sind mit diesen sagenhaften
inzidenz gar nicht um schärfere
maßnahmen mehr drum rum körper geht es
ja jedes land kann das schon machen
jedes land kann sich schon hinstellen
also herr kretschmann sachsen andere
können sagen was man auch bei uns die
situation so dass wir jetzt einschreiten
müssen das kann der doktor nennen wie
auch immer sich sowas auch nur bis zum
15 12 das ist aber das was die
bundesregierung an bietet dieses jahr so
das ist ja sehr viel differenzierter es
ist so dass in manchen regionen also die
nach schleswig holstein dazu versionen
incidents von wasser als ich 120 oder
gar nichts also nicht ganz so im
vergleich zu weil sie die 1500 1800 das
ist wirklich nichts vergleich wenn du
regional handeln kann es dann handle
regional aber und das ist eine
anforderung an die politik tue es auch
dann musst du dann auch wagemutiger sein
und sagen so dafür stehe ich und
notfalls wäre ich dafür abgewählt ist
mir egal ich mache das so und dann wird
keiner kann kein kein ministerpräsident
keine messe versendet wird sagen das
darfst du nicht da bin ich ziemlich
sicher und das ist das was politik
ausmacht und dann kannst du natürlich
auch noch die parlamente beteiligen ich
halte das nicht für ein widerspruch das
ist keine verzögerung sondern es ist wir
versuchen im einklang mit dem zu handeln
was notwendig an instrumentarium ist
ganz kurz noch wenn es unabhängig von
der rechtslage sehen sie einen lock down
für unabweisbaren jetzt so schnell wie
möglich den umzusetzen wird sich die
stadt soweit
ich sehe maßnahmen
gehört auch ein job down oder drei noch
down oder nancy sollen zwingend dazu
sage ich ihnen sonst sitzen wir in vier
wochen hier mit dem thema wie gehe ich
auf der intensivstation mit der
trassierung um was mache ich mit den
letzten bett wenn ich jetzt zwei
patienten hat der eine ist anwältin kann
der impfgegner gewesen und das andere
ist ein ins durchbruch von der 25
jährigen die vielleicht schwanger ist so
wenig dieses bett und ich befürchte dass
wir um diese trias führungsdiskussion
nicht herumkommen wenn wir jetzt nicht
tätig werden und dann nennen sie es mal
mit wegen lockdown oder kontakt
beschränkung oder sonstwas nur das
problem was ich jetzt in dem man dass
die parlamente gibt und auch und
regional ich weiß nicht herr neubauer
sehr sympathisch was sie gesagt haben
ich bin voll bei ihnen aber können sie
als bürgermeister sagen wir bleiben
jetzt alle zu hause oder brauchen sie
nicht im hintergrund den
ministerpräsidenten oder die
bundesregierung die ihnen die
rückendeckung gibt weil wenn sie das in
ihrem ort sein werden sie nicht mehr die
welt also mal abgesehen davon dass ich
es glaube ich verfügen kann aber als
kreisangehörigen kommunen bin ich
sozusagen der hausmeister im politischen
system also wir können das ohnehin ich
anführen wir können sehr viel auf
kommunaler ebene mit mit der bitte um
mitwirkung regeln das haben wir auch
glaube ich in den letzten monaten
wirklich gut hinbekommen wir wie auch
sehr stolz darauf dass das unsere
stadtgesellschaft dass das schafft aber
ich möchte auch mal auf das auf das
testen zurückkommen wir haben in
augustusburg im frühjahr neben tübingen
wollen wir die einzige offene stadt in
diesem land und wir haben das wir haben
im system voll digital integriert test
und kontrolle für den filmen eingang und
ausgang ähnlich wie es in frankreich
jetzt praktiziert nichts mit luca und
und uns kennt man irgendwie ein sondern
wirklich ein check in check out mit
integrierten testsystem vollständig
anonym und fälschungssicher die
akzeptanz dafür war groß wir haben eine
studie der uni mainz die gesagt hat das
hat funktioniert werden also wir haben
glaube ich 30.000 tests gemacht bis uns
dann damals die bundes notbremse auch
aus dem verkehr zog insgesamt während
der gesamten zeit und das ist wichtig
während der gesamten zeit ist die
inzidenz und unsere stadt
kontinuierlich gesunken weil die leute
testen gegangen sind regelmäßig testen
gegangen weil sie wussten dass es der
eintritt ins normale leben und genau das
hätte ich gerne wieder in der jetzigen
situation glaube ich tatsächlich müssten
wir alles jeden zutritt irgendwo wo
menschen zusammenkommen müssten zwingend
alle die dort erscheinen getestet ja so
wie wir heute wir sind auch alle geimpft
haben es getestet genau das brauchen wir
jetzt dann könnte man die menschen auch
wieder billionen mit ein bisschen mehr
teilhabe natürlich muss man immer noch
gucken was kann man machen großkonzerte
groß falsch versteht kein mensch warum
dürfen 20.000 leute und den fussball
statt und gehen ich glaube es immer ohne
maske ohne aktion alles aber war nach
inhalte werden statt das wirklich nicht
und und das sind da wird es in
inkonsistent und dann sagen die leute
bei mir im profil aber auch mädchen
brechen stecken dahinter ist garantiert
nur jetzt dass hertha union berlin derby
in der bundesliga es war die
europameisterschaft im letzten jahr hoch
umstritten vor allem die spiele in
london es war die olympische spiele in
tokio wir haben tische spiele in peking
demnächst also die das verstrahle ist
was sind also alle sind gleich aber
einige highlights aber dass das ist auch
nicht mehr zu verstehen das ist ja das
woran wir verzweifeln also du hast den
sachsen demnächst geisterspiele cluster
spiele aber rb leipzig spielt gegen
brügge ihn vor ausverkauften haus du
darfst keine weihnachtsmärkte besuchen
weil sie geschlossen sind aber du kannst
ins stadion mit 40.000 ohne abstand ohne
maske und das dann rom holen das
versteht kein mensch mehr oder
weihnachtsmärkte dann kommt herr scheuch
ein anderer soll forscher von hohen
graden und sagt ja jetzt verbieten wir
die aber in der schlange stehen ist auch
ein problem oder auch eben auch keines
so dann wirst du ja völlig wahnsinnig
oder du darfst den einkaufszentren und
du darfst du warst du darfst in clubs
aber du darfst dich auf weihnachtsmarkt
verstehen das ist doch alles hin und
vorne nicht durchdacht da muss ich sagen
da muss irgendwie mal sagen also remedur
geschaffen werden die leute müssen sich
damit beschäftigen und sagen das passt
vorne und hinten nicht zusammen und das
müssen wir einfach einheitlich regeln
und nochmal ich glaube dass vielleicht
jetzt nicht kommunal aber regional
schrägstrich auf landesebene
die instrumentarien da sind und dann
müssen sie angewendet werden und
angewendet werden können nur darum geht
es mir und das muss jetzt sagen wir mal
schneller gingen als es bisher gegen das
muss regionaler gehen als es bisher
gegen und dann muss man versuchen mit
möglichst schneller reaktion immer
weiter einzudämmen denn ich glaube es im
gesamten lockdown bis der sich aus hört
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher aber ich
bin jetzt kein virologen noch
epidemiologe bin ich mir gar nicht
sicher ob der die welle jetzt so
überhaupt bricht ich glaube du musst
wirklich sehr schnell gucken und dann zu
diesen ganzen sachen kommen diese zweige
ich habe auch nie verstanden dass das
ergebnis nicht was schnell funktioniert
ja das problem würde den tag an
funktioniert natürlich schnell ja
zeitlos der welt begleichen sehen wir
müssen das wir uns daran hindern von
mensch zu mensch über wollen springen
wir sind mit einem lob von daher würde
der lockdown sehr schnell hell und
übrigens sie haben nicht gelernt von von
demokratien also taiwan ist jetzt im
rasches system bekannter oder südkorea
die haben datensätze die wir nicht haben
die können das was was herr neubauer
sagt das können die sehr viel besser
machen als wir wieder eingeladen also
das vertragen es doch so ziemlich genau
das gegenteil dass genau diese
datenspeicherung ja eigentlich nicht
sein soll jaja und sagen wir so ich habe
jetzt nicht 177 sein wissen nicht mal
was ja schon los ja eben und da sage ich
da haben wir da hätten wir von anderen
ländern lernen können und lernen müssen
die dann ja auch nicht undemokratisch
verfasst sind und da darfst du dir auch
nicht zu fein sein aber dann haben wir
das ist wirklich eine große historie an
datenschutz
gerade in unserem gesundheitssystem
natürlich hätte man das irgendwann alles
ändern können aber da müssen wir einfach
sehen da stehen tatsächlich natürlich
sehr große interessen dagegen und das
hat hier ja auch in unserem land und
wieder eine andere geschichte dass man
dort n7 ist mit ich rede auch von den 30
milliarden euro einfach aber klaren
maßnahmen sich klar werden und sich da
auch bitteschön mehr auf die
wissenschaft verlassen insofern bin ich
auch sehr froh über den krisenstab denen
es dann hoffentlich dauerhaft gibt denn
was man jetzt hört ja jede
landesregierung hatte irgendwie ihren
expertenrat der wurde aber oft genug
auch monatelang gar nicht angehört über
den sommer jetzt zum beispiel und ja
dann ist man halt überrascht wenn die
wissenschaft weiß sehr sehr viel aber
wenn wir da unser ohr besser dran haben
können wir auch uns für die maßnahmen
entscheiden das glaube ich ist verhör
mich heute nur zu ebay gehört zu den
datenschutz sagen ich meinte das was er
noch sagte der anonymisierten daten
erhoben hat die zu einer senkung der
inzidenz eingeführt haben es geht nicht
darum dass wir jetzt alles wir alle
wissen will um gottes willen nein
sondern es geht um das was er
angesprochen hat das hätte man
bundesweit ausbauen können keine
gleicher ganz kurz wir müssen sich
nochmals kurz daran nehmen wir haben
leider nur noch eine minute das was
jetzt frau berndt da gesagt hat dies
also mehr auf die wissenschaft hören
wird ja auch in ihrem sinne sein
wir reden von politikern untereinander
ist sagen wir mal so ich kann ja eine
ganze liste aufzählen was wir
unsinnigkeiten jetzt gemacht wurden in
dieser pandemie lage wo wir am limit
sind da wurde uns die elektronische
patientenakte aufgedrückt das
funktioniert gar nicht da würde uns das
elektronische rezept aufgedrückt die
elektronische die klappt überhaupt nicht
geklappt in den praxen aber nicht eine
krankenkasse kam das m10 und wenn sie
das dann nicht umsetzen in der fraktion
werden sie noch bestraft ich meine das
ist doch ein irrsinn dass das konstante
sind von den sonstigen sachen reden das
bringt doch nichts wir haben nicht mehr
die zeit wir müssen schnell handeln und
auch dass die bürgermeister sind oder
die die regionalen parlamente geist
parlament oder werfen über das ist
völlig egal es muss was passieren weil
die zahlen werden sich in kürzester zeit
verdoppeln
weiter das nicht so positive schlusswort
aber wir bleiben verhalten das im auge
ich bedanke mich bei christina berndt
bei wolfgang rabe stephan-andreas
casdorff und bei birk neubauer liebe
zuschauer die nächste phoenix
gesprächssendung am sonntag vor um
demokratie da geht es um das thema wie
gefährdet ist unsere demokratie und das
hat ja auch sehr viel mit corona zu tun
moderiert von michaela kolster sonntag
jetzt folgt felix der tag mit michael
krons thema darin unter anderem die
reaktionen aus london vor allen dingen
zu dem flüchtlingsdrama dass sich
inzwischen zu einer flüchtlingstragödie
ausgeweitet hat auf dem ärmelkanal
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]